some multiple explosions have hit the
afghan capital kabul
including within the city's heavily
fortified green zone
the green zone is home to government
buildings foreign embassies and a busy
market square
police believe at least one of the
explosions was caused by a car bomb
which may have been targeting the home
of a government official
officials say at least six people have
been injured in the blast
all right for more now i'm joined by
journalist ali latifi he is in cowboy
good evening to you
what more can you tell us
so the last scene to target the
guest house of the current uh acting
minister of
uh defense bismillah
was not home at the time he shortly
after the blast he issued a statement
online saying that he's fine that
everything is okay that his family was
not
in the residence but there was still
gunfire there there's still explosion
sounds there's still smoke uh hours
after the attack
um and the attack was one of the rare
evening attacks
in the capital it happened at 8 pm um
and so it's uh it seems to have been
targeting the acting minister of defense
and and do we know any word on who is
likely
responsible
no group has yet to claim responsibility
um
obviously there are two major groups in
afghanistan the taliban
and forces claiming uh allegiance to the
so-called islamic state to daesh
but as of yet both groups have to remain
quiet on the issue
and have made no statements whatsoever
and ollie you know this
comes as foreign troops are being
withdrawn from afghanistan
how is this impacting the security
situation in the country
um we've seen you know several major
cities
come under heavy attack they've been
surrounded
uh in the nearby districts uh only a
week ago
this the the city of herat in the west
of the country near the border with iran
came perilously close to following the
to the taliban the taliban made it
within 10 kilometers of the main city
um over the last two weeks the the
southern city of canada has had a very
similar situation
and currently the city of lashkar-ga the
capital of hillman province
is also very much being targeted and
and is is very much under threat of even
a brief takeover by the taliban but so
far the government has responded
they've sent an additional they've sent
in commandos and special forces
and they've issued uh
curfews in in 31 of the 34 provinces
um so they're trying to turn the tide
and what about the the reports you know
these multiple explosions
that one of them or some of them being
inside the city's heavily fortified
green zone i mean that's something that
doesn't happen
every day
it doesn't but i think green zone is
kind of a misnomer in afghanistan
um you know it is still a residential
area there's still people that live
there there's markets there's stores
uh there's mosques yes there are
embassies there and there are government
officials that live
there but it's not as if that area is
somehow extra barricaded or
um somehow not open to the public
um you know i i think green zone is just
the term that people use but
it's really not that much more fortnite
than anywhere else in the city
okay journalist ali in latifi with the
latest tonight from
kabul thank you